peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
à la veille à d'un procès historique le
procès des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
comment vous l'avez abordé je crois que
les victimes attendent de pouvoir
témoigner une exigence de vérité une
exigence de justice nous allons les
accompagner du début de la crise jusqu'à
leur reconstruction dantec ce soit
possible pour certaines on parle
beaucoup de l'accompagnement
psychologique mais il ya tout un champ
d'accompagnement autres et
l'indemnisation qui est extrêmement
importante pour ces personnes la
problématique va être quel prix va-t-on
assigné à la douleur quel prix vaut
votre fille quel prix votre père et
c'est impossible c'est un procès pour
les victimes c'est un procès également
pour la république il ne s'agit de rien
d'autre que de juger des hommes qui ont
commis un attentat sur le territoire qui
doivent être condamnés
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mercredi 6 octobre foti
dépendez vaccination obligatoire contre
le kobe 19 à tous les français c'est non
pour la commission des affaires sociales
du sénat qui a rejeté cette proposition
de loi portée par les socialistes qui
prévoyait une amende pour les
contrevenants mais dans le même temps la
haute autorité de santé elle recommande
une troisième dose de vaccin pour les
soignants et ouvre même la voie à une
généralisation du rappel à tous les
adultes même si elle juge la mesure
encore prématuré à leurs obligations ou
recommandations appuyées peut-on
échapper à une troisième dose faut-il la
généraliser à tous les plus de 18 ans
alors que l'épidémie en france marque le
pas réponse dans un instant
le président français emmanuel macron et
son homologue américain joe biden vont
se revoir mi octobre pour parler de la
crise des sous-marins annonce ce soir de
jean yves le drian le chef de la
diplomatie française entendu au sénat
sur les conséquences de l'annulation du
contrat du siècle à l'australie est
exprimé longuement son amertume sûr je
cite des mois de tromperie et de faux
semblants n'en parle en deuxième partie
d'émission
[Musique]
au sommaire à 21h notre rubrique en
pensent les français le procès du 13
novembre 2015 se poursuit avec désormais
est victime du bataclan qui témoigne
depuis ce matin dans notre rubrique
ce soir nous irons à la rencontre de
l'un des survivants fred dewilde auteurs
de bd qui pour exorciser l'auteur de
l'horreur de ces attaques et sortir des
cauchemars des signes quotidiennement un
témoignage poignant à suivre
[Musique]
alors faut-il rendre la vaccination
contre le coc vide obligatoire pour tous
après les soignants pour la commission
des affaires sociales du sénat ce n'est
pas nécessaire la proposition de loi des
sénateurs socialistes n'a donc pas été
adoptée aujourd'hui de son côté la haute
autorité de santé recommande elle une
troisième dose de vaccin pour les
soignants on en parle avec notre
reporter guillemin rossi devant le
ministère de la santé bod books loire
guillemin alors pourquoi cette
proposition de loi du groupe socialiste
a été rejetée en commission
eh bien bon soir stéphanie bien
l'argument entendu bien c'est toujours
un petit peu le même qui revient et que
l'on a déjà entendu les sénateurs ont
préféré tenter de convaincre plutôt que
de contraindre écoutez
il faut continuer à augmenter la
couverture vaccinale s'en aller à cette
obligation l'obligation doit s'assortir
d'un contrôle si on oblige sans contrôle
on ne voit pas comment cela peut
fonctionner
un gamin les sénateurs avaient pourtant
dans les mains un rapport qui a liste
des éléments en faveur de l'obligation
vaccinale de quels éléments s'agit-il
bien stéphanie il s'agit de précédents à
commencer par le précédent de
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants une mesure qui a été très
critiqué par une partie des
professionnels de santé mais dans le
même temps au 21 septembre dernier plus
de 90 % des personnels de maison de
santé avait reçu au moins une première
dose plus de 95 pour cent pour les
libéraux il ya également le précédent
bien du pass sanitaires là aussi très
critiqués on l'a vu on a entendu maintes
et maintes fois pour des raisons
entendable diverses et variées mais dont
l'entrée en vigueur a elle aussi
participé à l'accélération de cette
campagne de vaccination
vaccination également accéléré en
nouvelle calédonie où la l'obligation
vaccinale à elle bel et bien été adopté
au début du mois de septembre dernier
voilà donc quelques arguments en faveur
de l'obligation vaccinale
avancer dans ce rapport remis au
sénateur les élus qui ont donc préféré
rejeter le texte en commission cette
proposition de loi socialiste qui sera
donc examinée en l'état en séance dans
l'hémicycle le 13 octobre prochain et
qui devrait en toute logique là aussi
être rejetée ce jour là également pas
d'obligation vaccinale donc mais
peut-être une une troisième dose a
ajouté à son pass sanitaires
ah oui et ça donc c'est la haute
autorité de santé 1 qui a recommandé une
troisième dose pour les personnels
soignants et les professions apparentés
comme par exemple les transports
sanitaires alors jusque là seuls les
plus de 65 ans et les personnes à risque
étaient concernés la haute dont la
généralisation de cette troisième dose à
toute la population se profile même si
la haute autorité de santé de santé la
juge pour le moment prématuré cette
haute autorité de santé qui a tout de
même déclaré je cite qu'une dose de
rappel deviendra bientôt nécessaire dans
les mois qui viennent merci gaymard
aussi en direct du ministère de la santé
et comme l'agencé européenne du
médicament la haute autorité de santé
recommande donc on vient de le dire une
troisième dose d'abord pour les
soignants quid du reste de la population
faut-il généraliser la troisième dose
pour tous les français alors que l' oms
alerte sur un nouveau corner virus
toujours pas sous contrôle place à notre
décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
véronique roger médecin généraliste vous
êtes également délégué et santé chez
debout la france bonsoir madame merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés pierre-jean
ternes amian radiologues et lui eu r ps
médecins libéraux en région rhône alpes
bonsoir monsieur merci d'être avec nous
donc feu vert est même show de
recommandations pour administrer une
troisième dose de la part de l' as ceux
qui craignaient cette fameuse troisième
dose on en parlait souvent risque de
revoir donc ce spectre devant elle et
elle est justifiée sur le plan sanitaire
véronique roger selon vous
écoutez d'abord je voulais dire que je
n'avais aucun conflit d'intérêt je pense
que c'est important quand les médecins
s'exprime de pouvoir le dire cette
histoire de troisième dose pour moi ce
que ça m'évoque c'est que bat c legault
vide n'a pas l'air d'être une maladie
très très et militante puisque et
vaccins ce n'est pas très très
protecteur non plus puisque au bout de
quelques mois six mois environ ben moi
j'ai bien vu dans ma pratique que
certaines personnes n'avaient pu
l'antico ou très peu mais j'ai vu aussi
les gens qui en avaient toujours
énormément et les anticorps continuer à
monter donc cette troisième dos et des
antilles que celles chez des gens des
patients des gens des personnels
soignants qui ont toujours des anticorps
moi je pour moi c'est pas de la médecine
on se précipite dans cette folie
vaccinale à vacciner des gens qui ont
des anticorps là vraiment je ne
comprends pas en quoi c'est pas c'est
pas médicale dans toutes les autres
maladies quand on a des anticorps on ne
fait pas de vaccin derrière
bon ben là c'est pareil les gens se
précipitent sur la 3eme dauger des
personnes des patients âgés qui vont
vers la troisième dose parce qu'ils sont
convoqués mais je regarde dans leur
dossier j'aurais fait une sérologie ils
ont des anticorps au plafond
si vous n'allez pas faire une troisième
dose avec des anticorps au plafond alors
moi je veux bien que l' agence
européenne de du médicament recommande
cette troisième dose mais bon moi je
fais de la médecine voilà
pierre jeantet remaniant c'est vrai que
quand on écoute le docteur roger on se
dit c'est quand même du bon sens ça veut
dire que on va faire une troisième dose
parce qu'on va évidemment conditionné le
pas de sanitaires à sa troisième dose
certainement en tout cas on en prend le
chemin même si pour le moment là là ça a
bien précisé que c'était prématuré
voilà quelle est votre opinion justement
de médecins pro vaccination
je pense que s'ils voulaient la france a
déjà un problème c'est que on plafonne
niveau de la vaccination de complète de
12 on n'est qu'à 75% et si vous regardez
la cour et les plates donc on arrive on
a un niveau de résistance représenté par
à peu près 25% de la population je
rappelle simplement à tous ceux qui sont
les détracteurs de la vaccination ce qui
s'est passé
excusez moi en martinique la réunion en
guadeloupe en guyane
au brésil où une couverture vaccinale
quasiment risible malheureusement à 20%
22% dans les dom tom alors peut-être
pour des motifs historiques liés un des
produits qu'ils avaient utilisé
autrefois pour se protéger et protéger
les plantations de l'ain en tous les cas
avec 22% si vous voulez de vaccination
on a été obligé de faire du tri comme en
médecine militaire pour les patients
atteints de komi donc tout le monde sait
et ce n'est pas une nouveauté et méchant
consoeur le sait aussi klein
capacité va dire unitaires baissent avec
le temps et avec l'acs donc c'est
logique toutes les agences qu'elles sont
recueillies française ou la chaise
demande à terme qui hier par forcément
tout de suite bien évidemment puisque la
publication française vient juste
d'avoir sa deuxième dose est quasiment
pour la majorité d'entre eux mais il
faut prévoir d'emblée une troisième dose
et puis il faut effectivement
généralisée rendent obligatoire la
vaccination ça ne choque personne que
les gosses soient vaccinés ça ne choque
personne car professionnels de santé et
une obligation vaccinale l'hépatite b ça
ne choque personne qui voulait en guyane
d'aller d'être vacciné contre la fièvre
jaune ou non de quoi alors effectivement
il ya des motifs on voit une grogne
d'une partie de la population et je
pense qu'il faut pas mélanger la
politique et la santé des transferts et
ça c'est un minimum
parce qu'on voit aussi bien des humains
parti de gauche qui demandent les
vaccinations la droite votre compte si
c'était la droite qui avait demandé ça
la gauche aurait voté contre mais on
n'en sort pas que ces systèmes en france
véronique auger votre réponse parce
qu'il ya plein d'éléments dans ce que
nous donne pierre-jean tard magnan qui
regardent manifestement que les
socialistes n'aient pas eu gain de cause
aujourd'hui sur cette vaccination
obligatoire
d'abord moi je voulais préciser que
contrairement à ce que dit mon confrère
en fait c'est ce que j'ai cru comprendre
je suis pas du tout anti vaccins
ont gelé même prescrit ce vaccin optique
au vide les prescrits à certains de mes
patients mais de manière ciblée je pense
que il faut c'est le bénéfice-risque en
a toujours appris seulement nos études
la vaccination c'est une affaire de
bénéfice risque commençons d'abord par
les patients à risque et on a bien vu
que les patients à risque c'était
principalement les personnes âgées les
diabétiques
et puis les obèses bien sûr ce et
évidemment les gens qui ont des
comorbidités donc si les gens ont
commencé par ces personnes là
avant de se précipiter sur les jeunes
je ne sais pas pour moi c'est une
aberration de se précipiter sur les
jeunes bon d'autant plus que moi moi je
parle de ma pratique je
l'assumé en tant que politique là je
suis en tant que médecin généraliste je
parle de ma pratique et faut voir tous
les effets secondaires que j'ai vu grave
évidemment je parle pas de la petite
rougeur ou de la petite
petite douleur au bras je parle d'effets
secondaires graves moi j'en ai vu
énormément je suppose que tous mes
collègues en ont vu aussi problème c'est
qu'il est déclare port moi je déclare
bon et je trouve ça énorme donc il faut
cibler la vaccination oui tout à fait
d'accord je suis pas du tout attiré que
ça paraît dans laquelle effets
secondaires
ben moi j'ai vu des effets graves j'ai
vu des insuffisances cardiaques j'ai
fait un infarctus j'ai vu des troubles
du rythme j'ai vu une thyroïdite auto
immunes j'ai vu un zonage et un petit un
petit adolescent 12 ans et demi un
énorme zone à
c'est parce qu'on est en train de faire
mais bon
et puis et puis aussi et énormément de
qovu de postes vaccination parce que mon
confrère dit qu'il faut vacciner
vacciner vacciner mais on sait très bien
que la vaccination tous vaccinés tous
protégés c'est pas vrai on connaît tous
dans notre entourage mais je pense
vraiment tous moi j'en connais
énormément qui sont venus me raconter
qu'ils étaient vaccinés et qu'ils ont
eue qu'ovide juste derrière nous pour se
traîner ce n'est pas dans sa forme grave
parce que c'est ce qu'on dit on n'a
jamais dit clinique c'est d'avoir le
covin mémé de finir à l'hôpital c'est ce
qui est dit en tout cas ça c'est un
jeune un jeune loup une personne de 40
45 ans qui n'a aucune maladie n'a pas un
risque énorme de faire une forme grave
loin de là autre ère et va faire une
forme légère alors si on veut aussi la
parole parce que c'est important ce sont
des arguments voilà et
la même opinion et c'est important de
donner aussi la parole à pierre jeantet
remaniant sur ses effets secondaires
docteur tard magnan premièrement et
deuxièmement sur la deuxième partie de
la réponse de votre consoeur votre
réponse
ma réponse est très simple je vais
l'inversé
clairement si vous voulez un peu
désobligeant pour les martiniquais ou
les réunionnais où les guadeloupéens de
les considérer que tout ce qu mauvaise
vieux et avec une immunité déprimé à 22
% de la couverture vaccinale il ya eu
des dizaines de morts par jour de jean
bonne santé qui est jaune 20 ans 30 ans
40 ans en martinique parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de couverture vaccinale vous
ne pouvez pas dire que vous allez
sélectionner les patients cette maladie
tue est d'autant plus que ces variants
delta
sur les effets secondaires encore
faut-il avoir une étude correct qui
vérifie bien que suite à la vaccination
il ya eu des problèmes
et pour ça il faut référence il est calé
déclaré et attendre de voir ce qui se
passe et voir quelle est l'analyse parce
que on peut effectivement dire je vais
faire la lessive ou fait un infarctus de
mieux qu'un il faut être un peu on veut
dire réaliste les les problèmes qu'on a
eus sur la vaccination sur tout à fait
mineurs contrairement à ce que vous
affirmez sur le rapport bénéfice risque
parce qu'on a évité et on a pu casser en
france métropolitaine une quatrième
vague qui aurait été sinon aussi forte
que la troisième vague avec des
centaines de morts et on n'a pas mis à
jour le système de santé au moment
clairement charnière du mois d'août où
les procès de santé que nous sommes on
était tous épuisés ou de deux ans
quasiment sans vacances au front en
d'autres termes c'est au front qu'on
était et on a quelques uns ont pu
prendre des vacances et à ce moment là
on se retrouve avec une quatrième essai
était la panique à bord on s'est dit si
jamais ça recommence à monter comme la
troisième la 2e la première vague que
fait-on on a déjà réquisitionné les gens
on n'a pas arrêté d'envoyer des avions
chargés de soigner un matériel aussi
bien paulin guadeloupe la martinique la
réunion maintenant la nouvelle calédonie
et on l'a fait pour tahiti parce que eux
aussi étaient soi-disant protégés par
leur isolement sauf que le virus bascule
aujourd'hui en tout cas quand on regarde
les chiffres on va les regarder
d'ailleurs les voir de santé publique
france on se dit que l'épidémie est
plutôt sous son contrôle un regard des
1475 hospitalisation sur les sept
derniers jours 262 admission en
réanimation 62 décès hier
justement on se dire on peut marquer le
pas sur la vaccination est ce vraiment
le bon moment de parler de delà de la
troisième dose docteur roger
ben moi je vous dis
cette affaire de troisième dose chez des
gens il me disait je comprends pas après
donc nous coffret redit qu'il était en
première ligne moi aussi j'étais en
première ligne vous savez j'en ai vu des
copies d'un
l'année dernière surtout parce que cette
année pas tellement et c'était pas du
tout les mêmes qu'au vide
j'en ai tellement vu que je les attrape
et moi même et donc je suis donc
immunisés et donc je vois pas pourquoi
je me ferai vacciner voilà séidou d'où
le fait que je ne je n'ai plus le droit
d'exercer d'exercer en ce moment ce qui
est comble dans une ville où il ya plus
du tout de médecins alors que je suis
pas du tout dangereuse ni responsable
comme l'état m'a dit le mât député a dit
que j'étais dangereuse et irresponsable
je pense que moi je suis sûr que je ne
suis pas du tout donc je comprends pas
cette politique voilà moi je fais de la
médecine je vois mes patients je les
soigne d'ailleurs parce qu'on a tout
misé sur le vaccin mais il ya quand même
des traitements qui marche très bien
donc si on soigne les gens si haut si on
développe les les hôpitaux parce que
vous parlez de l'outre-mer mais la
qualité des hôpitaux fin faudrait que
l'état se préoccupe de la qualité des
hôpitaux si on veut soigner les gens
fous quand même déjà qui est des
hôpitaux correct or là on continue en
france à fermer des lits voilà il ya des
soignants qui sont éjectés avec une
violence
sans pareille par l'état qui fait de la
médecine à la place des médecins ils
sont éjectés du jour au lendemain on
sait même pas quel est notre devenir il
ya les hôpitaux il ya des services dans
les hôpitaux en france qui ne sont
obligés de travailler à mi temps ou de
fermer parce que il ya des soignants qui
sont absents
ouais moi je moi je comprends pas cette
politique là la manière la médecine
comment justifier l'administration d'une
troisième dose alors qu'on n'a justement
pas atteindre la ville de tozeur 74%
le 100% de la vaccination ça veut dire
en gros ceux qui sont déjà vaccinés
bon se faire piquer pour pour les autres
pour déclencher cette fameuse immunité
c'est ça l'idée non pas tout à fait le
problème c'est que la vaccination a
débuté je dirais en janvier 2021 on
arrive au bout d'une année où on sait
très bien parce que c'est un vaccin qui
n'a pas il est dur et on veut dire
d'efficacité on va dire qu'il va
s'affaiblir un peu comme le vaccin de la
grippe qui a ri avec à chaque fois une
mutation potentiellement différentes on
sait qu'au bout d'un an limité va
baisser donc le principe même de la
vaccination c'est la prévention soit on
continue cet effort gigantesque qui a
été fait pour protéger la population
française et éviter qu'ils arrivent dans
des hôpitaux qui par ailleurs ont des
problèmes que l'on connaît tous que ce
soit d'ailleurs les hôpitaux privés ou
privés et les cabinets univers où les
médecins libéraux sont monde et ont des
soucis je dirais majeur actuellement à
gérer et à essayer on va dire de
survivre mais dans ce schéma-là la
vaccination c'est de la prévention donc
on arrive au moment où effectivement il
faut commencer la troisième dose et
surtout pousser des feux pour que les
25% dirait du tibre il ya un défaut on
va dire ou un
incompréhension sur la stratégie
vaccinale et puis vous n'empêcherez pas
une partie de la population de mélanger
la santé et la politique et ça c'est
l'hymne hameau dangereux alors solim
unité qui baisse à un dernier mot sur le
vaccin de pfizer
pas mal d'études montrent justement que
son efficacité diminue avec le temps
bout peut-être cette question de la
troisième dose qui nous pend au nez le
vaccin est efficace en regarder on va le
voir sur ces images à 88% les six
premiers mois
47% les six mois suivants
clairement est ce qu'on utilise déjà le
bon produit là on va pas refaire le
débat sur la vaccination mais déjà ce
qu'on utilise le bon produit est ce
qu'on est elle est peut-être trop vite
dans le choix des vaccins le docteur
roger selon vous
j'ai peut-être encore choqué mon
confrère en disant que si ça a été aussi
vite c'est parce que justement ce ne
sont pas des vaccins
ce sont des injections
susceptible de donner des anticorps oui
ça donne des anticorps mais on est
toujours en phase de test on est
toujours en phase trois de ces vaccins
jusqu'en 2022 2023 donc déjà je vois pas
comment on peut rendre obligatoire
quelque chose qui est encore en phase de
test
pierre jean talon justement sur le choix
des vaccins avec cette immunité qui
diminue qui va peut-être nous pousser à
faire c'est justement cette troisième
dose on essaie pour nylon neigeux d'hier
est l'exemple d'israël qui avait traîné
façon massive et qui commence à voir une
troisième dose et qui vous oblige vous
allez aller dans son territoire à avoir
nous donnons une deux une dose de rappel
c'est une dose de rap et après moi je
préciserai simplement lui maintenant en
israël justement est ce qu'on ne sait
pas plus imité sur sur le choix de
pfizer non c'est une quête sur les
risers kaiser si vous les gars il ya un
avant et après vaccination liés aux arn
messager il ya dix ans cette équipe on
va dire allemande a réussi à m on va
dire une thérapie pour les cancers du
poumon qui était en phase terminale et
qui marche sur et ils se sont basés sur
cette idée de la rn message est
d'utiliser cette technique qui sauvent
des vies pour essayer d'aller beaucoup
plus vite parce que si on est dans le
schéma vaccinal classique genre sanofi
par exemple sur des vaccins dits
traditionnels
automatiquement d une durée
d'élaboration de un an et demi quand on
a une pandémie qui vous arrive à vitesse
grand v et puis une vague de vagues
troyes vannes en moins d'un an vous
n'avez pas le temps de faire avec ça et
sanofi en est un très bon exemple
sanofi a fait un choix il ya dix ans en
arrière 12 ans n'a rien de ne pas
investir
regardez les centaines de millions
d'euros qu'ils investissent actuellement
par la technologie air et ça va nous
permettre non seulement de recombiner un
vaccin ans six semaines mais ça va
peut-être nous donner des vaccins contre
le paludisme ou d'autres thérapies qui
vont émerger parce qu'il y avait un
avant et un après la reine messager et
ça donne une protection et pfizer est
manifestement pour ceux qui ont une mono
doses johnson & johnson on leur donne le
razer pour avoir mais pour ma conscience
c'est clair que ayant vu le kobe de l'an
dernier la deuxième dose serait bien
probablement pour elle au moment que
sont évités va baisser et elle va
forcément baisser parce qu'elle n'est
pas je veux dire un éternel l'immunité
pour ce type de pathologie ce qui n'est
pas le cas pour d'autres productions et
on n'a pas le choix on prend le meilleur
on va dire actuellement sur le marché
alors on est bien effectivement phase
iii les échanges le est-ce que vous
imaginez le nombre de gens qu'on a déjà
pu sauver
mais oui un petit mot peut-être faire
l'un des projets ça sera la fin ce
nouveau pet
oui bah écoutez moi je pense que j'ai
sauvé des gens aussi avec des
traitements précoces et encore une fois
je suis pas du tout je suis pas anti
vaccins je dis qu'il faut être prudent
en médecine il faut quand même être
prudent il ya toute une toute une gamme
de solutions avant de se précipiter dans
cette folie vaccinale et moi de toute
façon je souhaite pas d'une société de
de contrôle de flicage de surveillance
d'obligations voilà moi c'est pas ma
manière de voir la société et on est en
train de balancer vers cette société
complètement inhumaine alors comme bon
moi je pense que le plus important c'est
la liberté c'est la vérité j'espère que
la vérité va éclater et puis quand même
là les relations humaines là on est
tombé dans une société où il faut
quasiment se dénoncer les uns les autres
si on est vacciné pas vaccinés ça sera
oui oui mais c'est important oui bah
c'est pour ça qu'on vous donne la parole
véronique auger précisément vous avez pu
apporter totalement votre opinion en
toute liberté ce soir sur ce plateau
avec le docteur pierre jean terme à
niort merci en tout cas à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté ce face à face
dans l'actualité incontournable ce soir
également la crise des sous marins avec
un nouvel entretien mi-octobre entre le
président français manuel macron et son
homologue américain annonce ce soir de
jean yves le drian le chef de la
diplomatie française qui déclare que
l'ambassadeur de france en australie va
rentrer à canberra après l'annulation du
contrat du siècle jean yves le drian
était auditionné aujourd'hui au sénat
sur les conséquences de cette rupture
d'accord au profit des états unis il
exprimé longuement son amertume sur jeu
si des mois de tromperie et de faux
semblants
à aucun moment enfin notre partenaire
américain et le royaume uni n'ont pris
l'initiative d'une information de la
france ou des contacts pris avec
l'australie en lien avec un projet
alternatif à celui dans lequel nous
étions engagés à aucun moment notre
partenaire américain n'a répondu aux
interrogations que nous le souhaitions
sur sa vision de l'état du projet que
nous conduisions à quelques heures de
l'annoncé du 15 septembre est alerté par
des fuites dans les journaux australiens
nous avons sollicité les autorités
américaines sur la véracité des faits
allégués par la presse nos
interlocuteurs américains ont à ce
moment là seulement
confirmer ces informations
après des mois de tromperie et de faux
semblants et malgré une mobilisation
constante de notre part la crise que
nous connaissons est grave
qu'elle n'est pas achevée simplement
parce que le dialogue est renoué
qu'elle va durer et quand sortir
requerra des actes forts plutôt que des
paroles l'abondance de souveraineté que
représente le renoncement programme
attaque et sur le saut dans l'inconnu
vous avez utilisé le mot que j'ai
utilisé dès le départ que constitue pour
les australiens le choix de recourir à
une technologie qui ne maîtrisent pas
qu'ils ne maîtriseront pas à l'avenir et
qui le met donc entièrement à la merci
des évolutions de la politique
américaine une perte du contrat du
siècle et une crise diplomatique entre
les états unis et la france qui s'en est
suivi au coeur aussi de plusieurs
discussions en coulisses anthony blinken
à paris pour tenter de recoller les
morceaux
entretien mi octobre entraînées macro et
joe biden on en parle tout de suite
vous régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france ce soir on apprend donc par la
bouche de jean yves le drian que
l'ambassadeur de france et rapatrié en
australie qu'il y aura bien une
rencontre une autre entre emmanuel
macron et joe biden cette fois ci on
devrait certainement ça y est on passe
l'épongé malgré quelques nuances en
termes de communication fin de
l'histoire quasiment alors pas fin de
l'histoire je pense il faut analyser
d'abord
quelques 10 les deux parties on sent
qu'il ya plus une volonté américaine de
dire oui oben voilà la crise est
derrière nous
ping anthony blinken et jean yves le
drian se sont se sont rencontrés ont
discuté emmanuel macron à a eu s'est
entretenu avec le président américain
tout ça montre quand même qui reste
quand même un profond malaise du côté
français on entend j'en iv jean yves le
drian dire qu'il faudra des actes pour
que pour mettre cette crise derrière
derrière la relation franco américaine
je rappelle quand même que les propos de
jean yves le drian il faut vraiment
l'air située au moment de la rupture du
contrat jean yves le drian a parlé de
coups dans le dos d'actes brutale qui
rappelle ce que nous faisait monsieur
trompe ce sont les mots de jean yves le
drian à l'époque donc qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire eh bien ça veut dire que le
ministre des affaires étrangères
français considère inconsidérés et à mon
avis considère toujours que la politique
étrangère américaine à fondamente changé
depuis l'époque trump et moi
j'ajouterais qu'au moins à l'époque de
donald trump il y avait une mérites
d'une certaine franchise c'est la colère
voilà tandis que là on nous a dit bah
oui joe biden est arrivé ça y est c'est
le sauveur tout va bien la relation avec
les alliés va être réparée on va arrêter
de se faire marcher sur les pieds et on
se rend compte que il ya évidemment le
plus grave cette crypte des sous marins
mais n'oublions pas qu'il ya le contrat
d'armement qui nous est passé sous le
nez avec la suisse un autre contrat
d'aviation aussi avec l'allemagne et que
finalement on a l'impression que les
américains
estiment qu'ils peuvent faire des coups
dans le dos comme ça aux français après
viennent rappeler effectivement que il
avait peut-être sous-estimé la force de
cette relation franco-américaine qu'il
fallait qu'ils entretiennent mais ce
qu'a fait monsieur blinken finalement il
a fait ils étaient là étaient
parfaitement dans son rôle le rôle du
francophone francophile qui a vécu à
paris qui considère la france comme sa
deuxième patrie on l'a entendu hier soir
sur france 2 on n'a pas entendu jean
yves le drian lui dire la même chose que
ce qui lui avait dit en juin bienvenue
chez toi en parlant de la france là la
france est quand même très gêné il ya eu
une une véritable voilà je pense que je
pense que la france s'y attendait pas
enfin elle s'y attendait pas no il est
clair que il y a eu tout l'été des
doutes des atermoiements on avait eu des
infos comme quoi le contrat comment
comme quoi il y avait de l'eau dans le
gaz autour du contrat maintenant une
rupture aussi aussi brutale sur un
repositionnement stratégique des états
unis dans la zone indo passé indo
pacifique
face à la chine je pense pas que on
avait anticipé que ce serait donc juste
brillant dit vrai au sénat aujourd'hui
des trahisons mensonges
il est de bonne foi selon vous je pense
qu'il est de bonne foi mais il y avait
quand même il aurait dû regarder ses
arrières parce que il y avait des signes
déjà cet été qu'il y avait ce possible
repositionnement stratégique et ce
repositionnement stratégique il va dans
tout un ensemble qui parle justement de
l'évacuation du retrait des américains
en afghanistan jusqu'à ce nouveau focus
militaires cette fois sur la chine
jusqu'à imposer des sous marins
nucléaires
nucléaire à l'australie pour qui vous
savez en australie nucléaire c'est un
gros mot
spécifiquement nous avions établi ce
contrat pour que les australiens
puissent bénéficier de sous-marin ssn à
classique avec toute la technologie
barracuda que nous avons expérimenté
mais qui ne portait pas la propulsion
nucléaire c'est ce que les australiens
avaient demandé et là les américains
devront entreprendre impose un nouveau
contrat en plus un contrat qui arrivera
en 2040 alors que le nôtre devait
prendre forme en 2030
en réalité on se trouve dans un la
france a été laissé pour compte de 7-2
ce repositionnement stratégique
c'est toujours america first
america first on le sait c'était le
grand slogan de donald trump on
s'aperçoit que finalement la politique
étrangère de joe biden n'a pas
fondamentalement changé et les états
unis d'une certaine façon prennent leurs
alliés à la légère au point
qu'aujourd'hui l'europe entière se
commence à ceux à se positionner sur
l'idée de l'europe de défense de la
défense qui commencent à revenir
aujourd'hui les parlementaires sont à
anould bien n'a donc en slovénie il y as
ils ont commencé à travailler travailler
sur une forme d'autonomie stratégique de
l'europe immédiatement critiqué
d'ailleurs bryan stow stenberg
donc le secrétaire de l'otan qui voit et
qui voit effectivement une velléité de
concurrence à l'organisation du traité
nord atlantique et que on se rend compte
que là il ya oui un instrument un
repositionnement une prise de conscience
peut-être des européens que dans
l'avenir il importe quand même que
l'europe puisse disposer d'une force si
elle veut marquer des points si elle
veut par rapport à la turquie par
rapport à tout un tas d'ensemble qui
commencent à émerger ce retrait des
américains il n'est pas simplement le
retrait des américains en afghanistan il
s'est fait aussi au moyen-orient au
moyen-orient des puissances ont émergé
en afrique également on voit la russie
qui est à l'offensive on voit la chine
qui est à l'offensive et mais la france
et l'europe s'interroge en disant nous
est-ce qu'on va être finalement
systématiquement à la remorque de l'otan
et la france en particulier se pose la
question de rester de façon
inconditionnelle l'allié des etats-unis
quand on voit comment les états unis
agissent vis-à-vis de nous justement
reste au sommet vous allez rester avec
nous parce qu'on va voir comment cette
affaire et vue de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique on va les retrouver thomas
bonnin en direct
washington bonsoir thomas comment
justement les états unis réagissent à
cette visite de la diplomatie américaine
en france
on peut pas dire vraiment que cette
visite d' anthony blinken en europe et à
paris plus précisément en fasse la une
des médias comme cela avait été le cas
au plus fort de la crise diplomatique
entre washington et paris mais tout de
même il ya un certain nombre d'articles
qui reviennent sur les enjeux donc de
cette visite du secrétaire d'état
américain il ya par exemple un haut
responsable de l'administration
américaine qui sous couvert d'anonymat
rappelle que bien la rencontre entre
anthony blinken emmanuel macron n'était
pas initialement prévu dans l'agenda
public du secrétaire d'état américain il
analyse ça comme un bon signal envoyé
par paris en vue de rétablir les bonnes
relations entre les deux pays alors il
revient aussi sur le contenu de ces
échanges qui ont eu lieu à l'abri des
caméras des discussions plutôt sur les
sujets de convergence plutôt que de
revenir encore une fois sur la crise
diplomatique qui a eu lieu apparemment
est les deux hommes ont parlé de prendre
des actions concrètes ces prochaines
semaines justement pour rétablir la
confiance entre paris et washington et
puis ici aussi dans les médias on
souligne beaucoup le fait qu anthony
blinken est en mission quasiment une
mission de rédemption de la part des
états unis on rappelle évidemment qu'il
est francophile francophones qu'il est
ami avec jean yves le drian revient
aussi beaucoup sur l'interview qu'il a
accordée à france télévisions où il a
reconnu que les états unis avaient eu
des torts dans cette affaire des sous
marins et puis l'autre aspect qui est
peut-être passé un peu plus inaperçu en
france mais qui est souligné ici par une
partie de la presse c'est l'interview
qui a été accordée par john kerry là
aussi à la télévision française il est
l'envoyé américain en charge du climat
mais il a aussi été interrogé sur cette
crise diplomatique
il a expliqué que joe biden lui avait
demandé des conseils lui avait demandé
ce qu'il se passait john kerry a dit dit
que joe biden avait véritablement pas
vraiment pris conscience de l'impact
provoqué par cette rupture du contrat
entre la france et l'australie alors il
ya beaucoup de médias notamment des
médias conservateurs qui s'attarde sur
ce point avec cette question comment joe
biden pouvait-il ignorer les percussions
que cela aurait sur la relation entre
paris et washington écouté par exemple
la tonalité dans cet article issu du
washington examiner
s'il dit la vérité cela veut dire que le
président des états unis n'avaient
aucune idée que la france un des plus
vieux alliés de l'amérique était
furieuse après avoir appris qu'elle
était écarté du contrat de technologie
nucléaire américain et ce n'était pas
une petite colère la france était en
fait tellement énervée qu'elle a rappelé
son ambassadeur aux états unis un acte
sans précédent pas du tout subtil
révélant clairement l'indignation est
une déception immense
et puis cette visite d' anthony blinken
en france se relance aussi ici les
débats sur les liens entre la france et
les états unis évidemment beaucoup de
journalistes dans la presse de la côte
est des états unis rappelle l'importance
à des relations entre ses alliés
historiques beaucoup reviennent aussi et
vous en avez parlé sur la comparaison
qui a été fait par jean yves le drian
entre joe biden et donald trump beaucoup
soulignent qu'il ya effectivement un
certain nombre de convergences dans la
politique internationale menée par joe
biden est celle qui a été menée en son
temps par donald trump et puis enfin
certains soulignent aussi que la très
forte réaction de paris dans ce dossier
et peut être aussi dû à la politique
intérieure dhs emmanuel macron lui qui
on le sait va sans doute se présenter
lors des prochaines élections
présidentielles en france merci thomas
bonnin en direct de washington régis le
sommier on l'a entendu john kerry et
certains médias plutôt de gauche 1 qui
affirme que joe biden n'aurait pas pris
la mesure de cette crise diplomatique
est-ce qu'il n'a vraiment pas pris la
mesure il s'agit de candeur ou il s'agit
tout simplement de d'indifférence ma foi
la réaction française qui n'a pas plus
d'importance que ça et qui est passé en
2d dans cette affaire je pense qu'il est
sait pas réellement qu il pas pris la
mesure je pense que joe biden est
parfaitement conscient de ce qu'il fait
il sait que les français n'iront pas au
delà
deux plaintes de je dirais de d'un jeu
diplomatique
certes sans précédent ça a été souligné
le rôle retrait laulom le rappel de
l'ambassadeur français des états unis
est un acte fort et qu'il n'était jamais
arrivé il ya beaucoup d' ambassadeur
quand il ya des crises qu'on rappelle
cette insigne c'est le premier signe
qu'il y a qu'il y ait rupture
diplomatique
en tout cas qu'il ya une tension là non
je pense que joe biden s'est
parfaitement que la france n'a pas les
moyens de riposter vis-à-vis des
etats-unis elle n'a pas les moyens
pourquoi parce que d'abord il ne s'en
donne pas les moyens
nous rend ancêtres que tout le monde
rappelle death et le général de gaulle
qui lui en son temps avait décidé de
quitter le commandement intégré de
l'otan pas quitter l'otan mais de
quitter le commandement intégré ça avait
été considéré comme un acte fort et de
gaulle l'avait théorisé comme un acte
d'indépendance nationale à l'époque pour
se placer justement pour placer la
france dans une sorte d'intermédiaire
entre la russie soviétique et les états
unis donc il ya eu déjà c'est ce qu'a
nicolas sarkozy a négocié a les dents
pendant son mandat le retour de la
france dans le commandement intégré le
si le retour de la france dans le
commandement intégré de l'otan nous fait
finalement figurer comme le deuxième
cercle des alliés des etats unis ce
qu'on voit bien que visiblement les
anglais sont toujours prioritaires là ce
qu'on appelle la spéculation elle l'est
toujours d'actualité elle est d'autant
plus d'actualité que les ans mais
maintenant on les coudées franches puis
avec le brésil mais que les australiens
et néo-zélandais voilà un certain nombre
d'alliés comme ça passe devant nous et
ça je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
demande de la part de la france et sa
une une redéfinition peut-être des à des
stratégies une redéfinition des
alliances et et ne pas suivre
systématiquement ce que les états unis
font en politique internationale et
baden sait qu'il n'aura pas que la
france n'ira pas jusqu'à cette rupture
c'est bien dommage parce que ça mettrait
les états unis devant
devant leurs actes de finalement et ça
montrerait que la france d'abord à une
volonté aussi de peser dans le monde on
seront remarque qu'aujourd'hui elle
s'est beaucoup fait face et elle a perdu
des points au moyen orient elle a perdu
des cartes qu'elle avait à certaines
époques même dans la crise libanaise par
exemple elle n'a pas été capable de
résoudre cette crise par rapport à ce
pays le liban avec lequel on a
énormément de d'alliances et de deux
traditions donc je pense que là il y
avait sciemment joe biden a joué de la
puissance et de la force américaine et
il a fait exactement ce qu aurait fait
donald trump probablement s'il était
resté au pouvoir merci beaucoup aux
régis le sommier pour votre analyse
et on en parle évidemment depuis
plusieurs jours l'envolée des prix du
gaz en france mais plus globalement en
europe face à des stocks bas et une
forte demande à la proche de l'hiver les
tarifs ont atteint des records
aujourd'hui certains européens mais
aussi américains accuse moscou de ne pas
ouvrir suffisamment les robinet pour
obtenir la mise en service au plus vite
de son gazoduc nord stream 2 la faute
aux erreurs des européens se défend donc
le kremlin des détails de notre
correspondante one crew à moscou même si
vrai dire poutine ne participa au forum
international du gaz qui se tient ces
jours ci à saint pétersbourg il s'est
tout de même exprimé sur la question à
l'occasion d'une visioconférence
consacré au développement du secteur
énergétique
il a livré son analyse sur l'envolée
actuelle des prix du gaz il a également
pointé du doigt la stratégie des
autorités européennes
la demande énergétique augmente et en
conséquence les prix mentir comme vous
le savez le marché mondial de l'énergie
ne tolère ni agitation ni turbulences
les plans d'investissement sont ici à
long terme tractée kanache qui
répliquent par
la pratique de nos partenaires européens
a montré une fois de plus qu'ils avaient
vraiment commis des erreurs nous avons
parlé avec la commission européenne
précédente et toutes ces activités
visait à réduire ce qu'on appelle les
contrats à long terme était axée sur la
transition vers le commerce gazier en
bourse il s'est avéré c'est aujourd'hui
absolument évident que cette politique
est erronée
nakasone je te parlais du village à
chicoutimi le président russe est
également revenu sur le cas de l'ukraine
qui s'estiment lésés alors que de moins
en moins de gaz transite via le
territoire ukrainien vladimir poutine a
rappelé l'importance de respecter ses
engagements
l'importance de respecter les contrats
signés entre les différentes parties
ne
se foulent guînes je dois hélas revenir
à la question du gaz il y a beaucoup de
spéculations à ce sujet gazprom estime
qu'il serait préférable du point de vue
économique est plus profitable de payer
la mandale ukraine tout en augmentant le
volume de pompage dans les nouveaux
systèmes ccir étant donné les
circonstances que je viens d'évoquer la
pression dans le tuer plus forte ou
moins d'émissions de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
tout est moins cher avec la différence
de presque 3 milliards de dollars pour
l'année mais je demande de ne pas le
faire il faut respecter toutes les
obligations contractuelles de transit et
de pompage de notre gaz via le
territoire ukrainien le système
ukrainien de transmission du gaz
première chose il ne faut mettre
personne dans une position difficile y
compris l'ukraine malgré toutes les
nuances lié aux relations russo
ukrainiennes à ce jour deuxième chose il
ne faut pas s'appeler la confiance
envers gazprom en tant que partenaire
absolument fiable dans tous les aspects
salon georges nous venions
de gaz il en est donc encore question à
l'occasion de ce forum international qui
rassemble tous les grands acteurs du
secteur le patron de gazprom le géant
énergétique russe va diriger la session
plénière qui va se tenir ce jeudi
après-midi entre la hausse des prix du
gaz mais aussi avec l'achèvement du
gazoduc nord stream 2 pour ne citer que
ces deux exemples les sujets de
discussion ne vont pas manquer et
vladimir poutine qui remet donc les
points sur les i concernant la flambée
des prix du gaz en europe on en parle
tout de suite avec claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claude blanchemaison de soi vous
qu'est ce qui a poussé le président
russe à s'exprimer aujourd'hui sur la
crise des prix du gaz c'est un contexte
particulier à cela ça peut paraître
surprenant parce qu'effectivement tout
le monde sait depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines que une situation du
marché mondial du gaz naturel qui est
que la demande excède de beaucoup
l'offre et ceci parce que l'économie
reprend heureusement après la crise du
que vides notamment en asie spécialement
en chine et que donc à une demande très
forte et que les pays qui produisent ce
gaz le fournil naturellement comme comme
comme d'habitude donc 7,7 tensions
existent aussi sur le pétrole d'ailleurs
à lorsque vladimir poutine a voulu dire
aujourd'hui c'est un la russie respecte
intégralement les contrats qu'elle a
signés est en effet une partie de ce gaz
est fourni sur à partir de contrats à
moyen ou long terme et il a répété ce
qui est exact que la russie respecte à
la lettre ces contrats que peut-être les
pays occidentaux et les pays européens
n'ont pas été très bien inspiré de
passer le plus possible en dehors de ses
contrats à long terme pour acheter du
gaz sur le marché au jour le jour on
appelle ça le marché spot à rotterdam
avec un prix qui s'établit au jour le
jour et effectivement il dit que la
russie serait prête à regarder le sujet
pour l'avenir et à conclure davantage de
contrats à long terme mais effectivement
l'esprit du temps le goût de la
commission pour la concurrence pure et
parfaite fait que les états membres vont
de plus en plus vers le marché spot
alors par ailleurs il a par la même
aussi indiqué que la construction de
structures fixes comme les gazoducs par
exemple vont plutôt dans le sens de
contrats à long terme puisque ça a
établi des relations stables et
prévisibles entre un fournisseur et des
clients il ya évidemment aussi vous
dites vous parlez de l'air du temps un
média aussi certainement ces tensions
qui révèle peut-être des divergences
politiques et diplomatiques dont on
parle souvent évidemment sur ce plateau
peut-être plus profond de la crise du
gaz qui cristallise les tensions entre
l'union européenne et la russie
sans doute une manifestation parmi
d'autres de cette situation politique
mais il faut quand même noter que le le
le parce que derrière cette affaire
naturellement tout le monde pense à la
sphère de nord stream 2 le le gazoduc
north stream ii a été terminée il a été
hachée il est actuellement en période de
test en période d'essai et on attend
pour sa mise en service que le
régulateur allemand certifie la
conformité de cet équipement aux règles
qui sont les règles allemandes et
européennes est évidemment plus le
régulateur allemand attend plus il y
aura une tension effectivement sur le
marché allemand et par conséquent sur le
marché européen alors choix qu'il faut
aussi noter que dans le fond cette
affaire concerne au premier chef les
allemands puisque eux dépendent beaucoup
du gaz russe pour leur approvisionnement
en gaz mais aussi pour leur mix
énergétique la france de dépens à 20% de
la russie pour son approvisionnement en
gaz et comme on sait elle a par ailleurs
beaucoup d'autres sources d'énergie
notamment le nucléaire l'allemagne sort
du nucléaire et par conséquent a besoin
de recourir davantage au gaz alors il ya
aussi peut-être une condition du côté de
la commission pour la mise en service
réelle de stream 2 c'est que la
commission à une directive déjà d'un peu
en ciel qui indique qu' on ne peut pas
utiliser une infrastructure que ce
serait d'ailleurs une infrastructure de
transport de chemin de fer par exemple
et avec un utilisateur qui aurait le
monopole de l'utilisation est en plus
une la propriété d'une partie de cette
infrastructure il faut séparer les deux
alors il faut espérer que la commission
insistera pas pour faire appliquer cette
directive et acceptera par conséquent la
vie dans la mise en service rapide de
nord stream 2 et claude blanchemaison
dans la question l approche de la coop
26 1 qui aura lieu à glasgow la première
quinzaine de novembre continue aussi des
impératifs évidemment écologique est ce
qu'on doit s'attendre à une pression
justement pour ralentir la production et
la distribution de gaz je ne crois pas
tous les économistes
du secteur de l'est connaît de l'énergie
indiquent que la consommation de gaz et
par conséquent sa production va
augmenter il va augmenter encore pendant
quelques dizaines d'années parce que
comme je viens de le dire à l'instant
par exemple en europe l'allemagne
sortant du nucléaire elle a d'ailleurs
un peu recours au charbon un peu trop un
peu trop par rapport aux normes des
coptes successives et on va à la
rappeler à l'ordre sans doute aussi à la
coop 26 en 10 ans il faut pas recourir
davantage au charbon mais par contre le
gaz présentement l'inconvénient en
termes d'émissions de co2 donc le gaz a
encore un bel avenir devant lui même si
effectivement à terme est bien la
priorité ce sera d'aller vers des
économies le plus possible décarbonés de
produisant le moins possible de co2 si
possible pas de co2 du tout mais il faut
à chaque pays revoient sont mixtes
électrique puisque pour faire
d'électricité il faut évidemment une
énergie primaire et si l'énergie
primaire n'est pas nucléaire et ça ne
peut être que du désir au carbure ou
bien il faut recourir aux énergies
renouvelables qui pour le moment occupe
une place assez faible dans les mix
énergétique des différents états merci
beaucoup claude blanchemaison pour cet
éclairage
et des prix du gaz de plus en plus
élevés donc qui ont poussé certains
ministres des finances de l'ue à faire
une déclaration commune pour le
commissaire la commissaire européenne
chargé de l'énergie cette hausse des
tarifs démontre la nécessité on l'a dit
est de développer des sources d'énergie
renouvelable et réformer le marché du
gaz en europe les précisions de peter
oliver correspondant verte et
international à berlin
ce que nous voyons là ce sont les prix
les plus élevés pour le gaz sur le
marché des matières premières qu'on ait
jamais vu en europe en fait la
commission européenne est en train de
sonner l'alarmé la commissaire
européenne à l'énergie kadri simpson a
dit que les plis pourrait bien continuer
à monter durant l'hiver selon elle cette
élévation des prix pourrait dépendre de
facteurs aussi inconstant que les
conditions météo selon à quel point
elles seront mauvaises pendant les mois
d'hiver à venir s'il fait
particulièrement froid on verrait les
prix d'augmenter considérablement même
par rapport au prix du gaz sur le marché
des matières premières on voit déjà en
ce moment
en conséquence cela a incité des pays
tels que la france l'espagne la grèce la
république tchèque et la roumanie cela a
poussé leurs ministres des finances à
faire une déclaration commune disons que
l'europe et l'union européenne ont
besoin de revoir complètement leur façon
d'acheter du gaz
en europe que les balkans occidentaux
souhaitent intégrer depuis près de 20
ans un sommet informel était organisée à
ce sujet aujourd'hui en slovénie entre
les dirigeants de l'ue et leurs
homologues des six pays du sud est du
continent l'adhésion des balkans
occidentaux est bloqué du fait des
réticences au sein des vingt-sept ont
fait le point avec farah mais qui tony
pitaro et antoine auger
une ambiance décontractée avant
d'aborder les sujets épineux ce mercredi
la slovénie qui soutient l'adhésion des
balkans occidentaux à l'union européenne
accueille les dirigeants des états
membres et les cinq chefs d'état des
pays balkaniques 18 ans après le sommet
de grèce qui avait laissé entendre une
perspective européenne pour l'albanie la
bosnie-herzégovine la serbie le
monténégro la macédoine du nord et la
province du kosovo l'intégration à
l'europe se fait toujours attendre
pourtant ce matin ursula von der leyen
s'est montré optimiste quant à la suite
des négociations
l'union européenne n'est pas complète
sans les balkans occidentaux
ma commission continuera donc à faire
tout son possible pour faire avancer le
processus d'élargissement et
l'intégration de la région dans l'union
européenne
nous voulons que les balkans occidentaux
fasse partie de l'union européenne et il
ne fait aucun doute que notre objectif
est l'élargissement
au programme de ce sommet des
discussions axées sur les thèmes de la
réaffirmation de la perspective
européenne des balkans occidentaux à
l'issue desquels les dirigeants de
l'union européenne devrait adopter une
déclaration sur laquelle les pays
concernés seront invités à s'aligner
avant le début des discussions le
premier ministre hongrois viktor orban a
clairement laissé entendre que les
négociations avanceraient qu'à condition
que l'europe revienne sur certaines de
ses réformes lieu doit changer sa
politique car la raison de la hausse des
prix est en partie du moins en partie de
la faute de la commission nous devons
donc modifier certaines réglementations
sinon tout le monde va en souffrir la
hongrie n'est pas concerné par ce
problème car nous avons un système de
plafonnement des prix et les prix en
hongrie sont donc en baisse le problème
pour la hongrie et la nouvelle
réglementation du green ville qui est
une taxation indirecte pour les
propriétaires d'appartements de maisons
et de voitures ce qui n'est pas
acceptable si les négociations sont
engagées et que les états membres et
iter leur volonté de travailler pour un
processus d'élargissement de l'europe le
durcissement des critères d'adhésion et
le contexte d'instabilité politique dans
la région font croître le doute
reprochant pays balkans une trop timide
lutte contre la corruption ou encore le
non respect de l'état de droit la
chancelière allemande a défendu sa
décision de ne pas accorder d'adhésion
d'ici à 2030 contrairement à ce que
souhaite la slovénie je ne suis pas très
attaché à ses perspectives dans le temps
je suis plutôt attaché à ce que nous
tenions parole si les conditions sont
remplies l'adhésion peut avoir lieu
jusqu'à présent aucun des pays n'a
rempli les conditions donc aucune
adhésion
faute d'avancée dans les pourparlers les
six prétendants à l'adhésion de l'europe
pourrait se tourner davantage vers leurs
alliés russes ou encore chinois de plus
en plus présents dans cette région
stratégique pour apaiser les tensions
dégage de coopération seront proposées
par bruxelles aux candidats à l'adhésion
à commencer par un plan d'investissement
de 30 milliards d'euros sur sept ans
dont 9 milliards seront utilisés pour
financer l'accès aux énergies
renouvelables et l'amélioration des
réseaux de transport dans la région de
quoi tenter de préserver la confiance
des balkans occidentaux
en attendant une éventuelle adhésion
passée avec nous dans quelques instants
notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français ce soir témoignage d'un
survivant des attaques du bataclan 2015
hauteur
de
bd qui exorcise l'horreur et dessine
quotidiennement un témoignage poignant à
suivre
[Musique]
en afghanistan le passage du pouvoir aux
talibans après vingt ans de guerre est
une défaite pour l'ensemble des
occidentaux en tant que membre de l'otan
un pays comme la france peut se poser
des questions sur la vision américaine
de l'organisation et la prise de
contrôle du marché des sous marins
australiens par les états unis montrent
qu'une alliance entre anglo saxons pour
faire face à la chine est en train de se
construire c'est un signe manifeste
d'une longue dégringolade de notre
posture à la fois stratégiques
politiques sur la scène internationale
et industriels aussi les pays européens
sont ils perçus comme des pourvoyeurs de
troupes de supplétifs au service des
états unis ou bien des alliés et de
véritables partenaires
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la communication des modèles mâcon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
tik tok est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et ça n'a plus
rien oui c'est pour se rapprocher des
jeunes mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup
trop déconnecté de la sphère politique
ils pensent eux ça va ramener les jeunes
à la politique dont il se
désintéresserait en lieu et place de
politiser les jeunes ça dépolitise la
politique en la rendant encore plus
cooney sq justement c'est une nouvelle
forme de communication assez verticale
utiliser des influenceurs pour ça comme
politique personnelle est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vraiment nouveau
d'utiliser des célébrités pour faire de
la propagande politique on s'en fiche
nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige la
france comme c'est son travail en notre
nom pour nous est dans notre intérêt à
tous
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous avez assisté à cette fabrication
d'une machine terroriste de l'est ce que
vous êtes surpris de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
pas du tout c'était attendu de toute
façon on savait que les talibans étaient
en train de revenir sur le terrain
depuis déjà des années ce qui a été
balayé ce ne sont pas les talibans c'est
al qaïda qui a été balayé en 2001 et al
qaïda et des talibans ce ne sont pas
deux concepts superposables comment va
vivre le peuple afghan dans les semaines
qui viennent on va assister à un
raz-de-marée humanitaire absolument sans
précédent y va y avoir des que non pas
seulement pour quitter le pays mais
aussi pour simplement avoir du pain est
donc là il est bien évident que la
communauté internationale doit se
mobiliser
c'est notre
devoir moral que de venir en aide à ce
peuple qui a souffert tant par le passé
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire notre rubrique on pense les
français le procès du 13 novembre 2015
se poursuit avec désormais les victimes
du bataclan qui témoigne depuis ce matin
dans notre rubrique
ce soir nous irons à la rencontre de
l'un des survivants fred de ville
d'auteurs de bd qui pour exorciser
l'horreur de ces attaques et sortir des
cauchemars dessine quotidiennement un
témoignage poignant à suivre
[Musique]
et depuis ce matin donc les rescapés et
les proches des victimes du bataclan
témoigner dans le procès du 13 novembre
ils doivent se succéder à la barre
pendant trois semaines pour raconter
leur histoire le récit est signée julie
est l'ami
c'était une nouvelle journée difficile
pour les parties civiles ce mercredi
s'ouvre est la cinquième semaine du
procès historique des attentats du 13
novembre
la cour a commencé à écouter une
quinzaine de récits de rescapés et
proches de victimes de la tuerie la plus
meurtrière de ces attaques celle du
bataclan des témoignages extrêmement
poignant se sont succédé une partie des
survivants ont exprimé leur sentiment de
culpabilité d'être encore en vie et si
certains ont bien sûr des blessures
physiques
tous ont raconté avoir des séquelles
psychologiques importantes des stress
des des cauchemars les nuits sans
sommeil les et les jours noirs
le même six ans après on se rend compte
de l'importance terrible des angoisses
qu'elle
qu'elles vivent alors nous on les entend
on les entend en entretien en
consultation mais ici c'est vraiment dit
publiquement s'est exprimé exposé
les parties civiles qui étaient
présentes à l'intérieur de la salle de
spectacle ont détaillé l'horreur
qu'elles ont vécu la panique les corps
les odeurs le sang une femme a raconté à
la barre avoir perdu l'homme de sa vie
nick alexander ce britannique a
rapidement été touchées par les balles
des terroristes
sa soeur explique pourquoi il est
important pour elle d'être présente au
procès je suis ici pour écouter une
autre histoire montrer que nous
racontons l'histoire de cette nuit là je
suis ici pour écouter l'histoire de tout
le monde nomo notre vérité parce que
nous ne pouvions pas être présents cette
nuit-là et cette grande solidarité
d'être aux côtés des autres victimes en
tant que famille nous nous sentons
impuissants dans ce procès historique
beaucoup de victimes attendent le jour
où auront lieu les premiers
interrogatoires des accusés après avoir
raconté leur histoire à la barre ce
mercredi certaines d'entre elles se sont
d'ailleurs tourner vers leurs boxes et
se sont adressés à eux ce qui est
vraiment à noter c'est cette envie qu'on
l'ait les parties civiles de s'adresser
directement aux accusés elle arrive et
elle s'adresse aussi aux accusés elles
ont des choses à leur dire ça c'est
incroyable à tel point que le président
a repris un peu les rênes en disant
attention
ces personnes sont présumées innocentes
mais vraiment il ya ce besoin chez les
victimes entre 15 et 20 audition porté
sur le bataclan sont prévus chaque jour
jusqu'à la fin octobre les semaines à
venir s'annoncent donc encore très
douloureuse pour les victimes et leurs
familles ces dernières estiment
d'ailleurs que l'aide apportée par le
fonds de garantie n'est pas à la hauteur
de leurs attentes et met en doute leur
statut de victime est l occasion de ce
procès du 13 novembre notre rubrique
qu'en pensent les français donnent la
parole ce soir à l'un des rescapés a
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de fred
de vie d'un dessinateur auteur de bd il
a passé deux heures allongé à côté d'une
jeune inconnu blessés elisa aujourd'hui
fred reste debout mais rien n'est plus
comme avant et pour exorciser l'horreur
qu'il a vues il dessine quotidiennement
un reportage de katia technique et
sébastien dufour
je suis en banlieue parisienne à la
rencontre de fred de ville qui est
dessinateur auteur de bande dessinée il
est aussi rescapé du bataclan et c'est
un sujet qui infuse son oeuvre récente
bonjour fred merci de nous accueillir
merci bonjour
oui alors faites vous vous dessinez tous
les jours vous dessinez des choses qui
ont trait à l'expérience traumatique que
vous avez vécu
l'expérience traumatique ou
comme certains disent à la résilience
aux débuts chez nous les tout premiers
dessins que je faisais c'était vraiment
les deux les dessins de l'attak et que
de latin qui est des trucs complètement
pour moi ingérable et puis au fur et à
mesure du temps je suis passé de plus en
plus dans des allégories
expliqué
la 7 3 on va dire trois morts
qui tente devrait attirer vers le fond
d'un océan
c'est un peu la veille du procès en fait
j'avais eu cette idée là ça représentait
assez bien
ma crainte par rapport au procès qui
était que le procès mre en même vers le
bas avec des choses que je pouvais
apprendre avec le fait de remuer tout ça
encore une fois même si on n y eut
toujours dedans
elisa on sait
de tous les deux la main elle a été
blessé j'avais voulu l'aider sans voir
qu'elle était blessée
et puis bah du coup je pouvais plus
sortir les le couloir était complètement
vide
et je me suis allongé dans le sens d'un
gamin qui était juste à côté de nous qui
étaient décédées et on a passé les deux
heures quasiment main dans la main lisa
et moi
as tenu en compagnie se tenir le moral
l'utilité calmes et livrées le fait
mais livre fasse du bien des gens me
donnent un rôle social ils ne font du
bien à la tête par rapport à tout ça
mais de se séparer de l'horreur que j'ai
vécu je sais pas si si un jour ce sera
fini et si je réussirai par ce biais là
à mon passé je suis encore
suivi et je suis encore sous traitement
je suis pas du tout pour le moment
capable de m'en passer je suis encore
et encore en état de stress facilement
d'une manière qui nécessite une thérapie
et oui ça c'est évident j'ai toujours
pas récupéré une vie normale j'ai
toujours pas récupéré un sommeil normal
j'ai toujours pas récupéré une
une capacité à sortir et à faire des
choses normalement finalement les gens
que je côtoie maintenant sont quasiment
tout le temps des victimes donc on se
comprend très bien entre nous on sait
très bien de quoi on parle on sait très
bien
ce que l'on vit est ce que n'ont recensé
par ce soutien là général l'antre nous
je pense qu'on a réussi à tenir si on
n'avait pas eu ça je sais pas comment
est ce qu'on aurait fait
les mangas
[Applaudissements]
on s'est retrouvé plongé
dans un massacre
nationale sais
c'est pas l'état n'est pas directement
responsable
n'empêche que c'est le rôle de l'état de
prendre en charge ces citoyens dans ce
genre de situation et de les prendre
correctement en charge du début à la fin
je veux dire on aurait on ne devrait pas
avoir à se battre pour être indemnisés
pour avoir les supports on doit avoir on
devrait pas à se battre pour courir
après le bon chirurgien ou le bon
psychologue après d'ailleurs si une
vraie difficulté que rencontrent les
survivants celle après le parcours
administratif par exemple c'est moi qui
ai dû faire toutes les démarches c'est
moi qui ai dû me battre pour pour tous
là je me suis fait aider parce que je
pouvais plus du tout le fond de garantie
c'est un truc extraordinaire et c'est
extraordinaire que c était et que c
était créé mais celle
la pro activité qui n'est pas là pour
ceux qui se retrouvaient dans une
terrasse et qui ont été miraculeusement
vivant au milieu
de tous ces morts pour ceux qui étaient
dans la salle pour ceux qui étaient
jédir surtout les six ce qui a été vu et
suffisamment marquants pour qu'on puisse
avoir
l'idée que l'on va être pris en mains
correctement le fonds de garantie me dit
mais vous dessinez toute la journée donc
tu as finalement vous êtes capable de
travailler
c'est juste complètement délirant
alors faites vous avez sortir un nouveau
livre nouvelle bd dans laquelle vous
parler cette fois de résidence j'ai
réalisé après coup que c'était de la
résilience parce que pour moi c'était
simplement
ces dernières années dont je parlais et
puis le combat que c'est
bon ça s'appelle conversation avec ma
mort donc c'est assez clair du type de
combat j'espère le finir sur une note
positive puisque je me dirige vers
l'algérie ont tous temps la mort c'est à
dire que c'est gagné mais enfin que
j'essaye en tout cas de gagner le combat
est alors que le procès des attaques du
13 novembre 2015 continue une question
se pose où en est le risque terroriste
aujourd'hui en france depuis ces
attentats il ya six ans 120 personnes
ont perdu la vie dans d'autres attentats
sur le sol français biel en bref et en
images
[Musique]
où
à près de 30 attentats qui ont donc
abouti sur notre sol en espèces de six
ans la sécurité et la sûreté des
français qui font partie les enjeux de
la prochaine présidentielle ces thèmes
dont s'emparent traditionnellement
davantage la droite et l'extrême droite
et ce sont précisément ces partis qui
semble avoir le vent en poupe dans les
sondages en ce moment ceci explique
tisme cela c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler danielle
simonnet oratrice la france insoumise
vous êtes également danielle simonnet
conseillère elle fit à la mairie de
paris bonsoir et merci pas avec nous ce
soir en direct un par skype avec 112 et
vice-président l ère du département de
l'essonne bonsoir alexandre tous et
merci
alors d'abord un état des lieux pour
commencer un tout le monde a parlé de ça
aujourd'hui il faut bien dire les
chiffres qui parlent d'eux mêmes sur ce
succès de la droite en france
aujourd'hui ce sondage a signé harris
interactive qui confirme la dynamique
eric zemmour qui atteint les 8 17%
d'intentions de vote or regardez
c'est la guerre de notre génération les
auteurs des attentats terroristes ne
seront plus libérable avant 50 ans au
lieu de 30 ans aujourd'hui pour que nous
soyons certains de les mettre hors
d'état de nuire
donc 17% ce n'était pas exactement le
bon graphique on qu'on souhaitait
envoyer ce n'est pas grave celui qui
n'est toujours pas déclaré candidat et
qui n'a pas de parti qui se
qualifieraient un tel choc du jour au
second tour même si méfiance évidemment
sur les sondages ça veut dire quoi
danielle simonnet clairement la france
se droitise zemmour is alors vous avez
dit méfiant sur les sondages vous avez
raison ces sondages quand même sa jeune
allemand refuse de prendre en compte la
moitié de l'électorat qui ne sais pas
encore pour qui le souhaitent voter et
donc il ya quand même un grand inconnu
suspens deuxièmement est ce que la
france se droitiser morize je pense que
la sphère médiatique ce zemmouri ça
c'est indéniable qu'une grande partie de
la sphère politique se mémorisent parce
que finalement vous pouvez regarder
n'importe quelle chaîne d'informations
en continu depuis des semaines et des
semaines c'est zemmour matin midi et
soir tout est fait pour organiser le
phénomène zemmour on sent qu'il ya une
volonté du système de à la fois
faire tomber marine le pen fait remonter
zemmour je pense qu emmanuel macron
souhaite un face à face macron zemmour
en se disant c'est comme ça que la
sentir et est ce que la france elle le
peuple français c'est zemmouri fier je
tends si beaucoup moins sûr pourquoi ce
que vous avez un autre sondage
aujourd'hui harris interactive qui
montrent par exemple que quatre français
sur cinq est contre finalement
l'allongement du départ à la retraite et
même pour l'heureux pour le retour d'une
retraite à 60 ans au que je sache ni
zemmour ni le pen ni macro ni heller ne
souhaite le retour à la retraite à 60
ans et le programme de jean luc
mélenchon et les thématiques par exemple
d'immigration d'islam interviennent que
en
10e rang 13e rang des préoccupations des
français et des françaises dans ce
sondage où on voit que la question
sociale est beaucoup plus importante
ainsi que la question écologique
alexandre touzet madame simone et nous
dit voilà c'est ce qui c'est le système
qui fait zemmour il n'empêche on connaît
bien le fonctionnement des chaînes
d'information je ne vais pas dans le tas
parce que on a un fonctionnement à pas
mais en général on met en avant ce qui
fait de l'audience aujourd'hui
clairement il exhume ont fait tilt de
l'audience est tout simplement les
chaînes info répondent et les médias
répondent à un intérêt grandissant du
public
alors je crois qu'il ya des sujets qui
sont structurels et puis à
l'effervescence médiatique il ya une
étude du civet peuvent qui mesure qui
est un film thanks deux sens pau qui
mesure 2 0 à 10 comment les français se
positionnent est en fait en l'espace de
cinq ans il ya cinq points en plus chez
les français de positionnement à droite
et on le voit en europe aussi d'ailleurs
et sa touche toutes les couches de la
société parce que ça concerne aussi les
jeunes il ya effectivement une
droitisation qu'on peut constater sur
ces cinq dernières années on gagne 5
points à droite ça c'est un phénomène
qui est
j'adhère structurelles il ya des thèmes
qui effectivement
jaillira interroge la population
effectivement quand on parle des sorties
sur des personnes qui ont été condamnés
pour faits de terrorisme avant 2015 ou
la justice était moins ferme on a un
sujet devant nous romain le sujet des
retours on a le sujet de la délinquance
qui augmente sensiblement dans le pays
ça ce sont des faits et puis à le
phénomène médiatique ou là effectivement
parfois hélas je peux partager
sentiment de mon interlocutrice c'est à
dire que on aime bien faire des bulles
médiatiques à toute élection
présidentielle en effet jean pierre
chevènement n'a eu françois bayrou si on
remonte dans l'histoire donc
effectivement il ya fans de deux bulles
médiatiques qui peut exister après je
mettrai en garde parce qu'on réfléchisse
parfois avec une histoire politique un
peu en ciel on a vu autour de nous que
ça soit en italie que ce soit aux états
unis mais ce soit en angleterre
des personnages un peu hors norme
émerger donc voilà je suis partagé entre
le phénomène de bulle médiatique
et puis une tentation populiste qui peut
exister
en europe et dans les démocraties
occidentales plus largement je dirais
pas un phénomène de bulle médiatique moi
je dirais que
l'intérêt du système et d'organiser une
certaine diversion ce qui devrait faire
la une de tous les médias vraiment le
sujet d'actualité depuis le début de la
semaine notre on devrait travailler je
dirais presque un mois durant au moins
c'est le scandale dépendre des dépens d
un peppers parce que vraiment c'est le
casse c'est le casse du siècle faut
quand même réalisé que onze mille 300
milliards d'euros qui partant en évasion
fiscale c'est vraiment un scandale sans
commune mesure parce que derrière il
faut se dire que c'est des hommes et des
femmes dans ton âme est donc en tête on
a les noms qui quelque part organiser la
case d'hôpitaux publics la casse des
écoles la casse de l'ensemble de nos
services publics nos politiques sociales
se faisant bon et le système pas intérêt
qu'on en parle faut pas oublier que la
plupart des chaînes d'informations en
continu sont tenus par 9 milliards d'eur
ces neuf milliardaires n'ont pas intérêt
à ce que le peuple prenne conscience de
toute cette évasion fiscale et donc on
va organiser la diversion et donc la
diversion savez de ramener à chaque fois
le sujet de l'immigration le sujet de
l'insécurité de ramener zemmour matin
midi et c'est pardonnez moi d'être si on
excelle à vue votre poulain et jean luc
mélenchon qui a fait ce débat qui a
rassemblé parce qu'il faut l'affronter
butin à personne ça fait une audience
effectivement assez forte chez nos
confrères
sauf que bon vous aime bien les sondages
mais oui quand même les sondages ça n'a
pas permis à jean luc mélenchon
d'émerger face à à eric zemmour qui lui
a pris du galon dans les études
d'opinion vous l'expliquez comment ça
veut dire que ces sujets dont vous nous
parler eh bien ça ne suffit pas vous
dîtes le social c'est plus important
mais il n'empêche les français semblent
s'intéresser aussi à ces questions
d'identité de
alors déjà ici je rappelle quand même le
sondage harris interactive du jour
montrent que la plus grande inquiétude
des français préoccupation c'est le
dérèglement climatique
ensuite c'est l'avenir des enfants je
les questions sociales arrive très haute
la question de l'immigration et l'islam
par exemple arrivent beaubien après bien
après donc ça c'est pour commencer
deuxièmement les sondages d'intentions
politiques montrent que jean luc
mélenchon est en progression et il est
le seul à gauche qui se démarquent
ensuite vous avez plus de 50 % des
personnes sondées qui ne sont pas sûrs
de leur vote et donc on ne prend pas en
compte dans le résultat du sondage bon
donc entre aujourd'hui et le jour de
l'élection les choses vont énormément
changé par ce compte on voit bien que
les sondages ont aussi un rôle
performatif est donc là je questionne
quand même
l'intérêt des médias de mètres de
présenter ces sondages sans jamais faire
un critique de ces sondages ou
d'expliquer comment sont-ils
constituer son miel type de panels et
sur quelle prise en compte des
intentions de vote alexandre est ce que
vous partagez ce diagnostic de de
danielle simonnet vous justement un
titre personnel vous expliquer comment
ce succès de la droite parce qu'elle
parle justement de sujets cas du mal
aujourd'hui à aborder encore la gauche
je veux pas rentrer forcément ce que je
trouve que c'est parfois un peu
complotistes comcom comme vision je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de médias et
quand on fait lors de chaque élection
présidentielle il y à des tests auprès
de journalistes sur leur sensibilité en
termes de candidats on a souvent des
candidats de gauche qui ressort donc on
va dire que la presse en général
est détenu par des à feu droitier du cac
40 je pense que c'est un petit peu
simpliste je pense que le monde
journalistique en france est plutôt à
gauche voilà donc je pense que ce
dernier le monde journalistique qui sont
propriétés des chaînes d'information
mélenchon faisait les résultats qui fait
auprès des journalistes je crois qu'il
serait président de la république donc
je pense ce jeu je m'éloigne un peu de
cette manière de penser je pense que les
partis politiques prennent en compte
aussi laurel et j'en prends pour qu'on
parle de l'a3 de la droitisation de la
droite mais il ya quelques ans quelque
part aussi une droitisation de la gauche
quand j'entends il apparaît témoin sur
la thématique de l'extrême gauche par
exemple parti communiste pensent
différemment vous en matière sécurité on
a eu des déclarations du secrétaire
général du parti communiste extrêmement
clair sur la question de la sécurité est
extrêmement clair sur la question la
laïcité j'en prends pour preuve que le
dernier gouvernement hollande dont je
n'appartiens pas longer n'est pas un
soutien à évoquer la déchéance de la
nationalité a fait des lois déception en
matière de sécurité publique donc ce
n'est pas qu'un phénomène ni médiatique
née qui concerne
j'avais à dire la droite c'est toute la
gauche en tout cas une partie de la
gauche qui évoluent sur cette question
là moi je suis les questions de sécurité
depuis très longtemps je me souviens
d'un temps où les mairies de gauche
pensait que les mères qui mettait en
place de la vidéoprotection état
d'extrême droite était ddd sécuritaire
affreux etc aujourd'hui vous avez
beaucoup de mairies de gauche où on fait
de la vidéoprotection on a des polices
municipales ou en armes ces polices
municipales donc on voit bien que c'est
c'est pas qu'un délire de la droite il
ya aujourd'hui des parties de des maires
de gauche qui font des actions en termes
de sécurité qui font des actions en
termes de prévention de la délinquance
qui réfléchissent au sujet de la
radicalisation
on peut pas dire que ces preuves
n'existent pas et il paraît donc notre
sens c'est il ya aussi une visualisation
de la classe pour un sens à long terme
gouvernement et je pense qu'il ya des
billets aussi une vision de la société
et c'est dans le cadre de l'élection
présidentielle qu'on peut se permettre
ces échanges moi je voudrais réagir
c'est que là où j'ai vont rejoindre ses
clients une certaine est mort isation
aussi dans la classe politique et pas
simplement dans la sphère médiatique
juste relaxe permet asiatiques entendent
est ce que je dis je ne parle pas d'eux
des journalistes en termes de
professions je parle du système
médiatique et donc de qui est
propriétaire des gros médias
audiovisuels et des chaînes
d'information ce n'est pas gagné mais il
n'est pas sur les chaînes d'info et
mémorisation d'une certaine classe
politique géré quand emmanuel macron
décide de passer un coup de fil à eric
zemmour pour s'informer de ses positions
sur l'immigration oui c'est une
banalisation de celui qui rappelons le a
été condamné pour racisme parce que le
racisme n'est pas une opinion mais un
délit quand il décide de diminuer de 50%
la délivrance des visas accordés aux
ressortissants du maghreb il s'est
nourri ce camp ont par contre de la même
manière quand vous avez une
manifestation des syndicats faction
d'extrême droite on faire pression sur
la justice
vous avez d'ailleurs eric zemmour qui
est présent avec monsieur darmanin et
qui est présent mais vous avez aussi
madame hidalgo monsieur jadot et
monsieur roussel et bien il se bascule
dans là où la gauche ne devrait jamais
allé par contre lorsqu'on a un débat une
confrontation
entre jean luc mélenchon eric zemmour
etc notamment on aborde la question de
la sécurité on voit que monsieur eric
zemmour m'a strictement rien à dire
parce qu'il n'a aucune
réflexion poussée
de refonte il ya des sujets regardez
jean luc mélenchon pour l'instant il n'a
pas beaucoup parlé terrorisme pour
revenir à notre chronique de tout à
l'heure trentaine d'engins mélenchon sur
la question chapitre aux sarthois dans
un seul but gros sacs la dernière encore
d'allier ces sujets là on attend le
chapitre 500 donnez moi on va le voir
d'ailleurs regardez sur cette
infographie chapitre 5 l'avenir en
commun vous parlez bien de la guerre
mais mais c'est pas exactement le même
discours que la droite est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas justement s'emparer de ces
français ces sujets qui sont quand même
malgré tout important sans l'été les
seuls à dénoncer
le
la question du financement du terrorisme
par exemple moi je me souviens toujours
par exemple ce sujet lafarge ou lorsque
le monde a révélé que lafarge pour
continuer d'exploiter une cimenterie en
syrie n'avait pas hésité à financer des
shs qu'à ce moment là les services
secrets français étaient en lien avec
lafarge pour récupérer des informations
et donc que le gouvernement français le
président de la république à l'époque
françois hollande et matheron et aidant
son équipe à l'elysée et bien ne pouvait
ignorer que nous avions là une grande
entreprise lafarge qui finançait
dash et qui d'ailleurs va être poursuivi
pour complicité de crime contre
l'humanité et c'est cette question
fondamentale qui est qui financent le
terrorisme
nous sommes les seuls à la portée
ensuite oui nous avons toujours dit
qu'il faut absolument développer les
moyens humains dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et au lieu de faire une
d'organiser que le gouvernement a pu
faire et bien une ambiance dans cette
société d' amalgame et qui vise à
encourager le racisme anti musulman
sans faire une distinction entre la
lutte contre le terrorisme islamiste est
par contre la lutte aussi sur ce qu'il
souhaite c'est à dire de la division de
la société parce que regarder toute
cette communication qui a été faite par
le gouvernement sur la question ce
concept inventé du séparatisme n'a aucun
impact dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme aucun la seule chose qu'il a
pour résultat c'est la banalisation du
racisme et on voit bien que l'objectif
des terroristes qui est d'organiser la
division de la société et bien et
l'autre face de l'objectif de l'extrême
droite et il se retrouve
alexandre touzet je voudrais justement
vous montrer avant de répondre à
danielle simonnet les propositions que
l'un de vos poulains pas encore
officiellement xavier bertrand par
exemple font sur ces questions de
terrorisme ne regardez
c'est la guerre de notre génération les
auteurs des attentats terroristes ne
seront plus libérable avant 50 ans au
lieu de 30 ans aujourd'hui pour que nous
soyons certains de les mettre hors
d'état de nuire pour vous aviez bertrand
ça suffit là le bon diagnostic les
bonnes réponses sur ces questions là
alors j'aurai peut-être revenir et on
voit bien la ligne de partage des eaux
règne de partage qui existe au sein même
de la gauche je pense pas que quand on
manifeste avec des policiers ont soit
contre la république je ne sais quelque
chose
pour cent de la population
qui apprécient sa police et sa
gendarmerie oui et je pense que
manifester aux côtés de sa police et
gendarmerie c'est tout à fait normal
c'est
de manifester aux côtés du cci enfin
voilà c'est ma façon de penser
avec des policiers des gendarmes qui
attaquent des islamo gauchiste je trouve
ça plus honorable et plus en lien avec
la république oui la manifestation que
ccf ont crié allahu akbar dans la
manifestation ni témoins sont partis
politiques d'extrême gauche se sont
fourvoyés quant à la question
de effectivement je soutient aucun
candidat dans mon camp j'ai décidé pour
l'instant d'écouté et éventuellement
prendre position dernièrement mais je
pense que effectivement la question des
retours de zone la question des sorties
de prison sert à la fois des personnes
qui ont été condamnés à des courtes
peines puisque avant 2015 avant les
attentats majeurs de 2015 les peines
étaient plus légère la question la
radicalisation en prison des droits
communs la question est effectivement
d'un certain nombre de français qui ne
sont pas qu'ils sont en conflit avec la
république
ces sujets là sont des sujets majeurs
j'ai travaillé notamment dans le cadre
des départements de france à la question
la radicalisation interne y compris dans
les services publics on a des vrais des
sujets majeurs qu'il faut traiter et de
et surtout qu'on sorte de ce faux
concepts distincts aux phobies qui est
un concept qui est un concept frériste
en fait qui souhaite opposer les
musulmans de france à l'état la
république en disant qu'ils sont
persécutés en france et musulmans ne
sont pas persécutés en france il n'y a
personne de persécuter en france on est
dans une république où chacun de vivre
et qu'on arrête de faire croire aux
musulmans que ce sont les damnés de la
terre que c'est prolétariat du 21e
siècle d'accord c'est une clientèle et
orale vous mais je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de route de remonter les
musulmans contre la république c'est une
grave erreur et c'est ce que les frères
musulmans souhaitent absolument et vous
tombez dans le panneau une façon naïve
et déconcertante de faire remonter les
musulmans contrat république la
république est ouverte il ya aucun
problème par rapport à ça mais
effectivement
il faut lutter contre l'islam politique
et moi j'assume de lutter contre l'islam
politique je gère pas une clientèle
électorale merci désolé on arrive à la
fin daniel simon et répondre à la
prochaine fois sur un prochain débat
merci en tout cas à vous de alexandre
trews et danielle simonnet c'est la fin
de cette émission se retrouvent demain à
20h et l'actualité qui continue ce faire
[Musique]
oui